Je mangerais bien dehors, quelqu'un connaît un bon Italien dans le 18 e ?
Tu veux manger un Italien? Il va d'abord falloir l'attraper! Mdr
Google est ton ami !
Oui j'ai cherché sur google et j'ai rien trouvé c'est pour ça que je demande .
Désolé mais moi j'ai cherché avec mon MAC et j'ai trouvé des trucs
Achète un MAC !
Ouais bonne idée comme ça tu n'auras plus d'argent pour t'acheter a manger
Achète un PC, à force de planter tu pourras faire un potager !
Ah ouais super la blague !
Ah ouais super ta mère
Super ta gueule
Connard !
Euh, calmez-vous les gars. Et sinon, mon Italien ?
Il court toujours !
Pierre Kiroule, on met une espace avant un signe de ponctuation double. Désolé, je suis un grammar nazi.
T'es une grand-mère nazie ? Tu fais jeune pourtant !
Attention, point Goldwin en vue !
C'est Godwin sans L, pauvre con !
Bonjour yoyo c'est maman je t'ai envoyé un mail sur le facebook de mon téléphone parce que la souris ne peut plus aller sur internet je fais comment bisous maman
Je sais pas maman. Cherche sur google.
"googl"
"http://www.google.fr"
Tu pleurniches pour un resto alors qu'il y a des enfants qui meurent de faim en Afrique ?
J'suis pas raciste mais les Africains heu ...
OK ! Et sinon personne pour mon resto ?
Pour manger Italien le mieux c'est d'aller au métro Rome !
Ah moi je connais un super resto dans le 19 e. Par contre, c'est un libanais et il est fermé aujourd'hui.
Tu devrais te faire à manger toi-même, ce serait moins cher. Surtout qu'à Paris, bonjour les prix.
Ah oui quand on choisi de vivre à Paris, il ne faut pas venir se plaindre après ...
Mais qui se plaint là ?
Oui moi j'habite à Rouen c'est moins cher.
Rouen c'est au bord de la mer ça ?
"discussion bruyante"
Bon. ça fait un moment que ça me travaillait, et j'crois que j'vais quitter Facebook.
Peut-être pour un moment, peut-être pour toujours, je sais pas. J'avais cru naïvement que venir ici ça allait combler le manque affectif qui me bouffe un peu
tous les jours mais je me rends compte que les interractions qui j'ai ici, ça n'arrange rien.
Le plus dur c'est pas la solitude, c'est le bruit tout autour.
Du coup, je prends les choses en main parce que c'est trop dur.
Comme ma bite !
voilà donc là si tu clique, "clac"  tu peux t'abonner
et en bas t'as un autre sketch, "haché ah steak-haché !"
J'te déteste !